I had not heard a thing about this movie
I knew nothing about Arthur Christmas
and now it was time to get into the
Christmas spirit
Arthur Christmas Arthur Christmas like I
said
so Arthur Christmas starts out it's
Christmas Eve Santa's delivering all
those gifts but she doesn't really like
you remember in a funny twist of events
Santa has gone so commercial he doesn't
actually do anything he has like a
million elves that all go to every house
simultaneously drop everything off it's
just this big operation San is just a
big fat guy he's pretty much the face of
the company which is funny because I was
watching it and I was like dude I've had
bosses like that if kids are watching
this review it's gonna go right over
your heads but remember kids you're
gonna have a boss like this you know
when you have that boss and the boss is
like okay you should do this so you go
and do that it's the wrong choice and
your boss comes to you it's like look
that was not the right call I mean why
did you do that he takes all the credit
none of the negative is his fault it's
like what's sad is like in this movie
and among all this commercial high-tech
north pole action you have Arthur who is
determined to bring this little girl her
gift on Christmas and that's our story
Arthur's on his quest to save Christmas
for one person now I like this movie for
a few different reasons one of which is
it addresses that Christmas isn't really
like what it was I mean among all the
commercialism and the really fast pace
you know got to get everything for sale
and it's just high adrenaline
high-octane stuff that malls these days
it's not really about family it's not
really about the spirit of Christmas
anymore and this movie addresses that
too like the most hilarious point I mean
the writing was really funny in this
movie too the dialogue was hilarious
when two people are arguing you'll see
something in the background you're like
well what was that why was that that I
know why that's there cuz I'm laughing
comic genius right there it had great
comedic timing and it's a really cool
adventure like it's cool seeing Arthur
go through all this with his two friends
that he has with him to save Christmas
for just one person one of Arthur's crew
being his grandfather this cranky old
guy was the best you know those really
cranky grouchy but really funny cartoon
old dudes this is him if I had an image
in my mind of what I would want Santa
Claus to actually be like it would be
this guy I mean honestly speaking there
hasn't been a Christmas movie to come
new into theatres in the holiday season
like this in years is it great yes is it
great for adults absolutely is it great
for kids you bet if you have a family
go see this movie this is the movie for
families to see this holiday season
because I don't think Harold and Kumar
shreya Lee you know the same family
level if you think just because it's a
family movie it can't be exciting you're
armed sir or ma'am the last 10 minutes
of arthur christmas are about as intense
as the last 10 minutes of Crimson Tide
I'm dead serious about that yeah I went
there and I mean it
Arthur Christmas is absolutely awesome
tacular you watch this movie with your
family this is gonna become like a
Christmas tradition in your house I
can't really think of a person who
wouldn't like it unless you just
flat-out hate Christmas in which case
the Muppets did make a movie about you
about 20 years ago so humbug to you all
right so I already asked you what your
favorite Christmas movie was so what was
your favorite Christmas gift that you
got in Christmas you know when you were
a kid you're like Santa does not exist
if this does not come and then it came
whatever it is comment below let me know
if any of you say Oscar Mayer wienie
whistle that's from a movie I know what
it's from and as always if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more
[Music]
you